sur france 3 une nouvelle émission
grimpe joyeusement vers les sommets fa
si la chanter
animée par pascal bruner et le succès le
plus récent de la chaîne récit de
l'aventuré par gym grossmann
si la chanter c'est au départ une idée
simple un orchestre joue des extraits à
vous de trouver le titre du morceau
mais voilà cette idée vient des états
unis
on examine très précisément la carrière
du jeu aux états unis dans tous les pays
où il a été exportée et on décide par ce
jeu a été un succès en angleterre en
italie en espagne ou aux états unis
d'abord aux états unis on décide de le
proposer ou pas aux chaînes de
télévision françaises
on
toujours se demander quand on essaye de
vendre un programme si c'est un manque
sur les grilles de programmes sur la
grille des programmes de la chaîne à
laquelle on s'adresse
c'est sur la mémoire la mémoire auditive
qui rappelle forcément des souvenirs
t'ai dit des chansons rappellent des
souvenirs et je crois que c'est ça la
force
philippe rapide encore toi que je t'aime
de vanessa paradis
dis-lui ton pote que vous avez été
convaincus d'avoir déniché le bon
concept il faut acheter les droits et
ensuite trouver un diffuseur
simplement il y avait des réticences de
la part de toutes les chaînes parce
qu'on l'a pas proposé uniquement à
france 3 il est sur le marché depuis au
moins quatre ans c'est un jeu qui
faisait peur parce qu'ils étaient liés à
la musique et la plupart des
programmateurs de télévision et là je
pense qu'on a prouvé qu'il se trompait
considéré que ce jeu était segmentant en
termes d'audience et mais avant de le
mettre à l'antenne il faut adapter le
jeu aux etats-unis par exemple ils
peuvent choisir les thèmes des chansons
mais ce sont les candidats qui font la
différence
philippe ici un candidat français
extrêmement concentré je vais dire une
plus facile maintenant de trouver des
candidats qui sont plus proches du
candidat type américain mais c'est vrai
qu'on n'aura jamais ce délire qu'on a
sur les plateaux américains
je crois que c'est mieux d'ailleurs
parce que c'est lié au caractère
français on est on est moins expansif on
est plus proche du jeu quand vous gagnez
1 m et une c se voit une image bien
jouer et gagner le voyage
regardez le le voici vous embarquerez à
strasbourg avant un grand bravo à
philippe pour sa superbe croisière
depuis strasbourg tandis que pour marc
barrât dans le même jeu et dans les
mêmes conditions elle repart avec un
piano un ensemble tailleur de luxe une
semaine de vacances pendant à nom de
montre à jacuzzi une parure et 500 mille
francs en liquide
on n'hésite pas à montrer les billets à
l'image ce n'est pas fini voici les clés
de la voiture de barbara en france il a
fallu compenser le manque d'eau et
d'excentricité des candidats on a donc
fait appel à un animateur chanteur
imitateur pascal bruner pour dynamiser
l'émission l'animateur s'est aussi
intégré au concept du joueur ou le jeu
s'est intégré à l'animateur mais qui
avait une alchimie parfaite dans le
choix de monsieur côté le directeur en
plaine
et ça marche les américains ont même
remarqué l'adaptation française les
américains parce qu'ils adorent notre
décor et qu'ils aiment bien la manière
dont on travaille et dont on a agencé le
décor avec l' orchestre centrale les
candidats la place de l'animateur avait
projeté ont projeté et vont tourner un
pilote ici même destinée à la vente
internationale
4 millions de spectateurs chaque soir à
20h sur france 3 c'est le succès on
pourrait penser pascal bruner enfin vous
avez trouvé le bon filon
parce qu'il ya eu quand même des essais
a toujours réussi pas toujours réussi
non mais je crois que le résumé de que
vous avez fait bien ragon bien
l'histoire c'est c'est une alchimie
entre entre le jeu et moi parce qu'au
bon là on ne voit pas bien mes dents
dans le dans l'émission américaine
l'animateur est un animateur il ne
chante pas pas d'imitation rien du tout
alors là avec toute l'équipe de
production on a je crois qu'on a bien
différencié les choses de manière à ce
qu'on puisse chanter les candidats
peuvent chanter à tout moment où il
hésite un petit peu on a vu qu'ils sont
moins expansif que les candidats
américains
donc j'ai le temps dans ces diables coup
plus d'épreuves dans le jeu américain de
l'ag trois épreuves bon j'ai plus le
temps de pouvoir les faire chanter de
jouer avec eux avec le téléspectateur
est donc bah ça permet de faire des
imitations de respecter en fait c'est là
c'est le bon dosage entre je crois à 50%
le jeu du jeu pur et 50% de chansons et
d'imitations mais quelle différence
quand même entre les candidats mairie
clair les candidats français
l'exubérance américaine et je serais
tenté de dire
la tristesse alors ça vienne quoi c'est
parce que vous ne savez pas et
d'émouvoir but j'en sais rien j'en sais
rien je
ils sont jamais jamais j j'aimerais tant
qu'une candidat d'une saute dans les
bras pour m'embrasser
mais une soirée flânant ils sont ils
sont comme ça
ils sont contents mais le ne montrent
pas faut dire aussi que l'enjeu n'est
pas le même
on a vu la différence entre le cadeau
que qu'on gagne chez nous c'est plus
modeste j'ai vu c'est un petit peu plus
modeste mais il faut faire des
sacrifices monsieur chance en pascal
renart vous faites tout vous animez vous
imitez jouer et les vérités vous ne
faites que votre métier jeu je pense
j'essaye de faire mon métier c'est la
première chose que j'ai faite c'est
d'abord les invitations le spectacle et
ensuite je suis
seulement à la télé il s'avère que la
dent fa si la chanter je peux faire ce
que j'aime chanter limitée et animée
j'ai pas envie d'être dans un équipe
étiqueté sur un rail et on en sort plus
je fais des spectacles en dehors de en
dehors de la télévision en province dans
les théâtres
il ya un spectacle avec les musiciens un
spectacle d'imitation pions ce qui
m'empêche pas de faire de l'animation et
même d'avoir fait la radio la télévision
est un plus mais qui vous ouvre
tellement grande toutes les portes les
portes du théâtre c'est j'imagine que
deux grilles
depuis le succès de fa si la chanter
vous avez peut-être plus d'engagement
contre faut bien sûr parce que justement
dans cette émission avec 7 avec ses
petites touches d'imitation qu'on peut
mettre quand on veut face à mme ça
montre aux gens qu'il ya aussi un
spectacle d'imitation qui a été écrit et
qui fait pour aller sur scène avec des
spectateurs qui sont là pour eux pour
rire car nous sommes presque à la veille
des présidentielles
que faites vous avec ces élections à
venir mais ça va donner que moi déjà je
vais me retrouver dans une maison de
repos et de retraite avec le camarade
krasucki qui sait toujours pas pourquoi
qui est là lui il sait même pas ce que
ça veut dire des parts de marché vous
comprenez jeannie parts de marché jamais
eux ils ont fait en dessous en dessous
de 12 à tout le temps en dessous de 12%
le sait moins que le pinard ou rendirent
alors il va mars à bon je vais les
garder quand même marche écrasé pas ce
que c'est c'est tellement bon vous dit
que la maison de retraite
oui je vais je mettre à la maison de
retraite je vais m je vais faire un
débat entre le ministre de l'intérieur
et jean marie le pen
un débat qui sera animé par opecst ça
met un 7 sur 7 popeck pasqua le pen et
le pen va évidemment trouvé que popeck
comme interviewer c'est une tentative de
diabolisation du front national et
ensuite je vais pas y avoir un edouard
balladur qui va se trouver dans un
temple inca et qui va offrir la tête de
jacques chirac en sacrifice
font refaire alors comme en ce moment
facile à chanter quotidien est un succès
forcément on pense à la grande émission
de 20h40
et ce plongeon est un bonheur sans solde
pour vous mais c'est aussi un péril ça
peut être un danger abel al gore faut
qu'il fasse gaffe le go pass qui les
points sur bon il y aura des surprises
les prochaines c'est sûr dans l'est dans
ce qu'on appelle tout casser août vous
tentez l'expérience on va la tenter
on va la tenter on va essayer l'année
prochaine vraisemblablement en tout
début d'année de faire ce qu'on appelle
les spéciaux ou émissions spéciales
alors on verra ça va durer déjà beaucoup
plus longtemps
on nous a c'est vrai qu'on nous reproche
souvent la rapidité de l'extrait dans
l'est dans les courriers dans les
lettres des gens qui disent
j'aimerais bien entendre un peu plus
longtemps ce morceau là là on aura un
petit peu plus de temps on pourra
peut-être faire un couplet un refrain de
chaque chanson mais c'est passé merci
parce qu'à l'inversé comme achats